sur 10 sorciers il y en a combien de
valables à votre avis très honnêtement
certainement qu'un seul et celui qui est
vrai celui qui est authentique en
principe il ne prend
rien dans l'enceinte des maisons de Dieu
règne la paix et la confiance mais à
l'extérieur traditionnellement se livre
le combat des forces du mal et du bien
sur les murs les frontons des églises
veille les gargouilles grimassantes les
mil visages du Diable car celui qu'on
appelle le singe de Dieu est aussi
l'objet d'un culte ses messes sont
noires ses prêtres sont les sorciers
tous ceux qui pratiquent la magie sont
condamnés par l'Église et pour être
libéré ils peuvent être
exorcisés
sal
miséric voici un grand exorcisme la
cérémonie pratiquée en cas de poss
c'estàdire quand le patient n'est pas
seulement envoûé mais bien habité par le
démon ce document est exceptionnelle car
l'Église catholique romaine interdit les
caméras pendant les séances mais cette
fois-là il y a plus de 10 ans
l'exorciste officiel avait donné son
accord le posséder également pour
témoigner contre
Satan
Satan du corps de votre
enfant
c'est dur
[Musique]
oui de H
comment expliquez-vous le développement
la persistance des des formes
d'envoûtement dans la société
actuelle moi j'y vois trois
principales directions la première c'est
que je crois et je pense que le diable
continue d'exister donc qu'il se
manifeste à un moment ou un autre de
façon plus précise c'est tout à fait
normal la deuxième chose c'est que nous
sommes dans une société où la
technologie est de plus en plus
prignante
et de moins en moins il y a des une
dimension pour je dirais le convivial et
une certaine irrationalité ou autre
chose si bien que on constate dans toute
société comme ça qu'il y a un renouveau
de des
religions et la trème la troisème je
dirais c'est par rapport à
l'église l'Église a eu besoin et je
crois que c'est une fois chose tout à
fait tout à fait saine de de de
rationaliser davantage la conception de
la foi de manière à à la purifier en
même temps parce que il y en avait quand
même bien besoin mais faisant il y a
toute la dimension de la religiosité des
hommes qu'elle a moins pris en compte et
cette dimension de religieux des hommes
de ce besoin de religiosité va
s'exprimer et va prendre des chemins qui
peuvent être certaines fois très
[Musique]
perverse exemple de religiosité
peut-être perverse
Ida qui vit entouré d'images pieuses
elle dit en tirer force et inspiration
pour exercer son métier de médium
radiesthésiste pendant 3 ans elle a vécu
l'enfer avec un démon en elle c'était
une possession selon elle car selon la
hiérarchie catholique sur 10000
personnes se croyant possédé une seule
le serait peut-être
vraiment c'est une femme qui était amie
avec moi que j'avais adopté qui était
entillaèise je ne suis pas raciste du
tout bon j'ai des amis dans toutes les
races et cette femme quand je l'ai
rejeté parce que j'ai vu qu'elle faisait
de la magie sur moi alors là elle m'a
complètement envoûté c'it un envoûtement
vaudou à votre ave oui oui un vaûtement
vaut doux un vaûtement vaut dououx euh
d'ailleurs je lui avais donné des tas de
vêtements
euh je ne regrette pas bien sûr mais je
pense qu'on ne devrait pas tellement
donner des vêtements à quelqu'un qui
peut devenir une ennemie comme cette
femme qui m'a prise pour pour une
ennemie pour finir quand je l'ai rejeté
elle a dû enterrer certains de mes
vêtements et puis voilà où je me suis
retrouvée la nuit dès que je fermais un
œil j'avais des visions des des visions
de choses horribles j'entendais l'esprit
qui me parlait enfin le plus fort je
parle les viatan qui me parlait
tuetoi je t'auraiis si c'est pas toi ce
sera ta fille j'en aurais eu l'autre il
me fallait quelqu'un de très compétent
c'est comme ça que j'ai atterri chez et
avec grande confiance je me sens guider
quand c'est comme ça
conforblement donc ENP si vous pouvez
regarder toujours vers la partie ha dans
la partie astrale pour se faire
exorciser ida est donc allé voir un
sorcier le pape des lucifériens celuici
uise
où les divinités de différentes
religions sont appelé à l'aide pour
déloger le
démon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pendant
l'exorcisme
l'exorcisme ce fut quand même affreux
pour moi bien que je j'essayaé d'être
maître de moi à certain moment quand
l'esprit voulait sortir il commençait à
sortir et il remonta vers les jambes il
descendait vers les pieds hop il
remontait directement vers la tête comme
s'il ne voulait pas sortir Ilou pas me
quitter d'ailleurs je pense qu'il l'a
dit à travers moi les viatant où te
caches-tu à l'intérieur de cet
humain je suis dans le
ventre qu'est-ce que tu y fais je m'y
PL pourquoi ne veux-tu pas sortir de cet
endroit et habiter
ailleurs je pars et je je
reviens car je m'y suis
habitué pourquoi fais-tu souffrir cet
humain mon devoir est faire
souffrir est-ce que tu veux sortir de
cet
endroit
non nous pouvons t'y
forcer alors essayz
sors je te
l'ordonne
au nom de Dieu
vivant
écoute au nom de Lucifer les viatan sors
Lucifer te demande de ressortir de ce
corps d'humain il n'a pas habité je suis
jaloux de cette femme tu ne
peux
vous pensez maintenant qu'il est parti
ah oui heureusement je me sens tout à
fait différente et puis beaucoup plus de
joie enfin maintenant j'ai envie de
vivre alors qu'avant je n'avais plus du
tout envie de vivre et je ne le ressens
plus si vous voulez je ne ressens plus
cette chose phénoménale s'acharna contre
moi quand je travaille et dans la nuit
je dors tranquille je passe mes nuits
tranquillees et mes journées
tranquille les sorciers pour la plupart
s'empressent de dire à tout visiteur
malen point qui est envoûté et propose
immédiatement un traitement adéquate
certains d'entre eux toutefois plus
honnête ou moins Cupid estim qu'il peut
y avoir d'autres causes au malaise du
client ils cherchent à vérifier s'il y a
envoûtement ou non et font passer des
tests comme celui de l'huile par exemple
al voilà vous allez tremper votre doigt
dans cette huile et vous allez me
disposer TR gouttes en triangle comme ça
de façon à ce qu' touche pas entre elle
et à ce qu'elle ne touche pas le bord de
l'assiette main droite ou main gauche la
main que vous voulez le doigt que vous
voulez
euh c'est à peu près tout c'est à peu
près tout et vous ne secouez pas le
doigt surtout hein vous les laissez
tomber parce que si vous secouez le
doigt voilà voilà
quelqu'un qui n'a un problème
voilà quel type de problème auriez-vous
pu déceler et bien j'aurais pu dceler un
problème de maléfice si par exemple vos
gouttes c'était cette première goutte
s'était dissoute d'un seul coup j'aurais
j'en aurais conclu que vous étiez très
fatigué et que vous
aviez par exemple
un un problème physique intense sur le
moment qui peut être simplement un rumme
de cerveau mais ça peut être un problème
physique intense si les deux premiers
goutte cétait dissoute j'en aurais
conclu que vous aviez des problèmes
psychiques j'entends si elle se dissolve
instantanément c'est qu'au moment où
elle tombe elle s'étale et si la trème
goutte sé étalée instantanément et bien
j'en aurais conclu qu'à ce moment-là
vous aviez effectivement un problème de
[Musique]
maléfice autre test pour savoir s l' en
est envoûté ou non celui de l'œuf
Jean-Luc CARADO fait donc le tri entre
ses clients il a écrit des livres pour
mettre à la portée de tous une partie de
ses connaissances c'est un érudit en
magie de toutes
sortes à votre avis un retour
d'affection est-ce que c'est possible
dans certains cas oui mais dans très peu
de cas est-ce qu'un envoûtement de mort
c'est
possible oui mais c'est très difficile à
faire c'est pas à la portée de n'importe
qui il y a finalement peu de gens qui
savent faire un avroûtement de mort en
revanche comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure il y a certainement beaucoup de
gens qui arrivent à créer des maléfices
parfois très grave uniquement
par une sorte de méchanceté
obsessionnelle vis ou de haine
obsessionnelle vis-à-vis de
quelqu'un est-ce que aussi quelque chose
qu'on demande très souvent paraît-il que
les clients demandent très souvent c'est
l'impuissance du partenaire est-ce que
ça c'est possible et facile
l'impuissance du partenaire
oui c'est
possible mais je crois
que la méthode est quand même
relativement
perdue il s'agit d'une ouand
d'aiguillette normalement il faut une
verge de loup fraîchement tué et un
lacet de cuir de de cuire de je ne sais
plus quoi la verge de loup fraîchement
tué c'est assez dur à trouver alors à
moins qu'on soit suffisamment calé pour
pouvoir adapter
la recette ça devient très difficile à
faire qu'est-ce qui n'est pas possible
qu'est-ce qui n'est pas possible ben si
on vous promet de vous faire gagner au
loto par la magie ça me paraît pas
possible pourquoi pourquoi tout
simplement parce que tous les mois il y
a quand même euh peut-être de ou 3000
marabou qui font un travail pour essayer
de gagner au l'OTO euh il y a peut-être
de ou 3000 personnes qui chacune dans
leur coin se concentre sur les numéros
qu'ils ont joué il y a 3 ou 4000
radiesésistes professionnel ou amateurs
qui font tourner leur pendule pour
essayer de savoir quel est le numéro qui
va
sortir et que par conséquent pour
arriver à passer au milieu de ce fouilli
il faudrait vraiment que vous ayez une
puissance
[Musique]
fantastique les sorciers ne manquent pas
ce n'est pas compliqué de le devenir il
suff de s'installer du jour au lendemain
sans diplôme sans contrôle les clients
non plus ne manquent pas ce n'est pas
compliqué de le devenir il suffit
d'avoir de l'argent mais il est plus
difficile d'obtenir des résultats car le
milieu professionnel des sciences
occultes est extrêmement mélangé il va
du simple filou au sorcier sincère et
peut-être doué en passant par celui qui
aide simplement en écoutant un peu comme
une assistante sociale
cette poupée qui symbolise la personne
que tu m'as demandé de faire
revenir le grand moment est venu où
l'être aimé va revenir à tout jamais
vers toi pour cela tu vas prendre ta
main
droite et tu vas piquer ici à cet
endroit quand je te diraiis pque pense à
l'être
aimé
pique
enfonce sur 10 sorciers il y en a
combien de valaable à votre avis très
honnêtement certainement qu'un seul et
celui qui est vrai celui qui est
authentique en principe il ne prend
rien cette véritable science quand elle
existe et qu'elle est vraiment très
profonde ce don ce
pouvoir en principe c'est presque comme
un ermite il reçoit ceux qui viennent le
voir avec beaucoup de compassion
beaucoup d'humanité et normalement il
doit rien prendre ça doit pas devenir
une situation
[Musique]
matérielle les anuires téléphoniques
donnent parfois de curieux
renseignements comme cette publicité
très bien placée mais non
vérifié les clients victimes
d'escroqueries sont nombreux mais
difficiles à trouver ils ont honte et
préfère se cacher certains pourtant
osent porter plainte en avril je suis
allée voir un magnétiseur médium
télépathe parce que je me sentais
fatiguée enfin un tout petit peu déprimé
je pensais qu'il allait me remonter bon
il m'a impressionné du début il m'a fait
peur il m'a dit qu'effectivement j'étais
très atteint alors que je ne pensais pas
et qu'il fallait que je prenne son
remède sinon sinon ben je serai internée
pour des pressions nerveuses alors bon
ben j'ai accepté de prendre le remède
puisque j'ai été très très effrayé bon
ce remède se se chiffré à 1600 francs
pour trois boîtes plus 250 francs de
consultation euh bon ben j'ai accepté ça
en demandant de payer en quatre fois bon
ce qu'il a accepté avec hésitation me
demandant de pas mettre de date ce que
j'ai fait sur l'échec sur l'échec
ensuite à la suite de ça je suis
repartie un petit peu ENF j'étais pas
tellement en forme et puis alors quand
je suis revenue j'ai contacté quelqu'un
du meilleur lieu pharmaceutique et
médical qui m'a dit que bon ben il
allait analyser ses ses pots ce qui a
été fait bon ça ne souigne absolument
pas le mal dont j'étais censé être
atteinte à la suite de ça cette personne
a encaissé mes quatre chèqus par d'un
seul coup sans tenir compte des quatre
paiements
échelonnés et puis bon ben moi j'ai
porter pleain c'est
[Musique]
tout la clientèle des sorciers est
souvent composé de personnes naïves
malheureuses crédules dont il n'est pas
difficile
d'abuser souvent oui mais pas
uniquement madame franquy en a entendu
de belle en 37 ans de carrière
elle n'accepte plus que des demandes
positives comme ce travail sur
photographie destiné à inciter deux
jeunes amoureux à se marier oh Dieu
tout-puissant je
t'invoque ainsi que tes anges de
bienfaisance
aide-moi pour que tu puisses m'aider à
unir ce couple qui s'aime qui ne peuvent
pour l'instant se marier je te prie de
m'aider je t'en prie Dieu
tout-puissant
aide-moi les femmes en particulier nous
demande de la mort de leur mari parce
qu'elles sont amoureuses d'un autre
homme et
qu'elle je leur dit bah pourquoi la mort
j'ai dit divorcé c'est tout le divorce
est très facile en France vous pouvez
divorcer ah ben non non non parce qu'il
faut que je laisse mon appartement ma
voiture je veux
tout il faut absolument que quiil
disparaisse alors j'ai dit alors vous
voulez la voiture l'appartement les
enfants l'amant et et tout j'ai d lui il
a droit à rien il faut qu'il meure quoi
elle me dit oui oui c'est ça bah j'ai
dit écoutez à ce moment-là vous irez
voir quelqu'un d'autre parce que moi je
fais pas ce genre de chose uneem et
souvent et chez les femmes on peut dire
qu'il y en a 60 % qui vous demande la
mort du mari vous êtes la seule à
pouvoir recevoir de telles confidences
ces personnes ne peuvent pas parler de
cette façon-là ni au curé ni au médecin
jamais de la vie jamais de la vie elle
ne parle qu'à nous hein c'est évident
elle ne parle qu'à nous c'est c'est
évident elles auraient trop honte d'en
parler ailleurs personne ne le sait il y
a que
nous avec nous elle ne se gêne pas aussi
bien de parler de sexe ou n'importe quoi
elle ne se gêne pas du tout j'ai eu par
exemple j'ai eu des des femmes qui m'ont
dit je voudrais aimer passionnément
avoir un amour sublime je voudrais que
cet homme même au point de venir manger
dans ma main qui me parle à genoux vous
voyez bien que c'est pas normal tout ça
on peut pas dire et quand vous les voyez
alors en dehors de mon cabinet ce sont
des personnes que vous côtoyer
journellement et et que qui vous semble
absolument très équilibré et
normal Philippe Gouz ce breton au
pouvoir mystérieux vient se ressourcer
se rechargé dans le temple de l'anlef
construit comme un sanctuaire druidique
comme une clairière en pleine
forêt ici il communie avec les secrets
de la
et les traditions celtiques l'une des
anciennes sorcelleries
[Musique]
occidentales rempli d'énergie le sorcier
guérisseur peut retourner vers ses
clients il traite toutes les maladies de
l'eczéma au cancer mais il refuse les
malaises traditionnels de la Bretagne
magique les sorts les envoûtements ou du
moins il les appelle
autrement quand quelqu'un me parle
d'envoûtement je lu dis rassurez-vous
c'est une simple dépression nerveuse
c'est une psychose c'est éventuellement
une paranoïa mais ou ce sont des
troubles maintenant on a toujours
tendance c'est une solution de facilité
c'est assez infantile à vouloir c'est
pas moi c'est l'autre c'est de
l'animisme un petit peu de bazar il faut
toujours trouver une cause la plus
facile soit-elle un bouc émissaire en
face d'un trouble en face d'un malheur
bon et bien le voisin l'envoûeur le
sorcier à bondau les psychoses le 16e
siècle les bcher nous on a connu et on y
était pour rien donc a priori je naai
pas envie de rentrer en jeu
[Musique]
là je pas il est par à l'hôpital là je P
pas
dormir un cachet quoi depuis il peut
plus m passer maintenant et oui c'est ça
le phénomène de drogue vous vous
retrouvez drogué à 80 ans comme comme un
jeune c'est pas marrant je vous faire
dormir moi je vais vous rafistoler un
petit peu alors bon ben je vais
m'occuper de
vous
bon comme ça
[Musique]
oui
on vous a vu faire des passes ou imposer
les mains qu'est-ce qui se passe à ce
moment-là j'en sais rien si je suis
extrêmement honnête avec vous je n'en
sais rien l'important c'est que je
guérisse il semble qu'il a un transfert
de quelque chose peut-être de l'énergie
en tout cas c'est suffisant c'est un
simple vecteur mon suffisant pour
générer chez mon malade ses propres
propriétés ses propres possibilités
d'autorégénéressance c'est lui qui va en
fait trouver sa propre énergie mais sous
mon contrôle maintenant comment se fait
ce transfert de contrôle je n'en sais
absolument rien si je suis honnête je
n'en sais rien tout simplement en tout
cas ce n'est sûrement pas du magnétisme
le magnétiseur travaille sur une énergie
périorganique tout comme le le
l'acuponcteur qui à mon avis sont
pendant extrême oriental et bien moi je
m'occupe pas du tout de l'É coror je
m'occupe de la pulpe ce qui est
complètement différent de
la vie et de quelle manière par quel BIA
je n' sais
rien ce mystère satisfait pleinement les
clients tout prêt à croire au don
magique vous sortez de chez le
guérisseur là qu'est-ce qu'il vous a
fait des poses de
main sur la tête et puis sur le
ventre parce que j'ai des problèmes un
petit pe partout l peut-être mais là ça
va pas je suis très fatigué
non un pouvoir
certain j'ai senti la
chaleur jusqu'au oreilles quand il avait
l'imposition des mains sur ma
tête
les moi
aussi je pe dire que c'est comme pour
moi c'est
comme
[Musique]
quel rôle donnez-vous au sorcier ah ben
c'est un rôle avant tout de
psychothérapeute c'est la magie en somme
de la parole la magie surtout de la
parole du malade qui peut se confier qui
a trouvé une oreille enfin car il faut
bien dire que nous les médecins
officiels n'avons pas toujours l'oreille
disponible au malad les gens qui
viennent me voir ont ce que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui un complexe par exemple un
complexe ça renvoie très exactement à ce
que les sorciers décrivent comme un
esprit un complexe négatif c'est un
esprit négatif qu'on l'appelle comme on
voudra en effet complexe c'est la
dernière appellation en pathologie
mentale et notamment psychanalytique
mais ça n'est qu'une étiquette pour
recouvrir une force qui dépasse
l'individu qui en souffre alors vous
êtes sorcier donc je suis sorcier
fondament
la psychanalyse à mon sens est une
émanation aujourd'hui de la sorcellerie
avec une mise en scène avec une
initiation avec un vocabulaire
avec des des incantations à
elle
l'empire des morts les ossè sont les
plus beaux lieux du monde pour un Spirit
luciférien marcher entre les
entassements de squelettes contempler et
méditer le purifie le régénère Octave
cber affirme pouvoir communiquer avec
les morts après certaines invocations il
prétend faire venir un esprit d'humain
de démons ou d'animal sur le plan des
vivants manifester sur les feuilles de
parchemin par une matérialisation de
leur forme la tête ou le corps et
l'esprit reconnu délivrerait un message
mais face à la caméra les esprits
étaient sans doute perturbés et
l'opération n'a pas bien
fonctionner sur ce
parchem ça y est nous avons un visage
complet et c'est le visage de la mort
regardez on voit bien on a carrément la
tête de mort là
elle est
nette voyez ça change après parce que de
la tête de mort d'un seul coup ça
devient un museau de
loup alors le le bout du museau du loup
le nez l'œil gauche l'œil droit le
front les dessins restaient flou Lucifer
a gardé son secret et son adepte n'en
dira pas
plus comment se fait-il que certaines
entités vous
obéissent ce sont des daiman ou énergie
c'estàd que on utilise pas que des
entités on utilise aussi des divinités
donc dans le principe de croyance
polythéiste les divinités obéisse pour
une raison c'est qu'entre le sorcier et
le magicien et ses divinités il y a le
mot
amour à partir du moment où il y a mot
amour il y a le mot invocation et il y a
le mot
respect et pour ce [__] magique vous
faites intervenir qui donc ça sont les
secrets de l'occultisme en général ne
doivent pas être dévoilés parce que le
jour où on saura quelle est la puissance
qu'un médium peut obtenir en déplaçant
un objet à distance sans l'IDE des mains
je pense que les scientifiques pourront
détruire une ville en un/art de seconde
je crois que ce n'est pas pour tout de
suite donc tant que les secrets de
l'occultisme restent
cachés je crois que le monde a une
possibilité de
[Musique]
survie savoir ce qui se passe dans
l'autre monde sans abandonner la vie
terrestre est l'un des plus vieux désirs
de l'humanité c'est aussi le but ultime
de la sorcellerie de
l'occultisme Octave sieieber se promène
souvent au cimetière du père la chaise
avec une émotion particulière car de
nombreux médiums spirites y sont
enterrés plusieurs dizaines de
sépultures sont encore aujourd'hui
l'objet d'un culte particulier de la
part des initiés des sacrifices parfois
des offrandes de toutes sortes des
attouchements ou encore des prélèvements
de terre ou
[Musique]
d'ossement parmi ces tombes la plus
visitée et la plus fleurie celle d'Alan
Kardec le fondateur du
spiritisme la magie et le surnaturel ont
donc des charmes toujours puissants
après tout au-delà de la raison n'y
a-t-il pas de place pour l'intuition
l'inconscient la folie le
[Musique]
rêve